Can parasites get into your brain and cause issues?
I did address that on that last question,
but the answer is yes.
So you do have a blood brain barrier
that is actually created by your astrocytes,
which is a type of glial cell that wraps around
your blood vessels that go through your brain.
And its purpose is to keep things from getting into
the neural cavity that shouldn't get into the neural cavity.
The problem is is that you can damage those cells
and you can have a damaged blood brain barrier.
So a damaged blood brain barrier is not a whole lot different
than a damaged gut barrier.
Henceforth the name permeable got or leaky got.
You can have a leaky brain, a damaged blood brain barrier.
It's very common.
And things can get into that into the brain
that you don't want to get into the brain.
Like just circulating toxins or things that you're exposed
to in parasites are one of those.
That's the real damaging part about getting your child
vaccinated before they're three years old.
I don't think she can get vaccinated at all,
but that's my opinion.
Why should you be even more careful of what your child
is exposed to in general before they're three years old?
Because you don't have a blood brain barrier
until you're three years old.
Do you have a non-existent blood brain barrier
for a six month old and you're injecting all these poisons
into them with all these adjuvings
that go right across because there's no blood brain barrier.
And it's damaging the brain and it's causing neuroinflammation.
And now they're having issues five years later, you know,
two months later, 10 years later, 30 years later
because of that damage to the brain.
So anything that gets across that barrier
or that non-existent barrier or a damaged barrier
can cause damage to the brain.
And it can be parasites, it can be toxins.
The first step is it's going to damage microglial cells.
That's the scammaging immune system, detoxifier,
lymphatic system of the brain.
Those microglial cells get damaged.
They can stay in a primed condition
where they spew out of inflammation.
That causes more problems, can cause all sorts of symptoms,
depending on where those damaged microglial cells are
in the brain, if they're in the primal lobe,
they're going to cause more symptoms like a pain and numbness
and tingling, if it's in the frontal lobe,
it could cause confusion and forgetfulness
and executive function issues.
If it's in the amygdala, it's going to cause more mood disorders
and PTSD issues.
And if it's in the occipital areas, it could cause site issues.
And if it's in a temporal area, can cause anywhere
from auditory issues to...
So, depending on where that damage is being spewed out,
is where the person's going to have symptoms.
And then it moves to a greater issue
because then you can end up developing antibodies
to neural tissue.
And that's what we would see in a Syrex 7x test.
So, yes, the answer is yes.